and Fairmont hotels around the world
there is an elite fellowship that was
founded 17 years ago right here in
Canada the fellowship of canine
ambassadors I've been a canine
ambassador at the Fairmont Chateau Lake
Louise for eight years now what a life
this is let me tell you my name is
Marcus and I'm the resident good boy at
the Fairmont Chateau Lake Louise this
here is a magical place Banff National
Park in Alberta Canada home to almost
10,000 foot mountain peaks meadows
covered in wildflowers and glacier lakes
that are the richest shade of blue
that's bear he's the new pup over at the
Fairmont Banff Springs
he's a bit more high-energy than me
we canine ambassadors live with a member
of the Fairmont team and what we do with
our hotels is simple make people feel at
home when they're away from theirs as
the wise old home than I am I've learned
a lot about the world I've made sure
that bear knows all the secrets to
happiness here I've let him know about
giving kisses greeting visitors at the
front door accompanying visitors on
hikes and I've also let him know about
the one kind of extra special visitor
these guys if you want to know about how
we feel about being canine ambassadors
here's an idea come by and see for
yourself it's a good life